on va passer à miss france alors parfois
du mal à dire son nom dont je ne
souhaite pas la palme à la quotité pas
eu mal à ma chavez qui a fait une belle
belle promo campagne de promotion et moi
j'aime beaucoup cette miss france
profonde à leur avenir et éduque rappelé
ma préférée et elle a gagné le premier
cas chapeau qu'elle est invitée
honnêtement allez un peu le feu aller
simple sur le flot de remarques un peu
désobligeantes vous a fait une petite
enquête regarde non chaque année au mois
de décembre c'est le même rituel
et oui c'est le 15 décembre 2018 qui a
été sacrée vague malama chaves alias
miss tahiti depuis son élection il ya
trois mois on a la chance de pouvoir
l'admirer toutes les semaines sur les
plateaux de télé de france mais son
marathon médiatique est connu quelques
turbulences
et vous allez voir que ça n'est pas si
simple d'être une miss france il ya une
dizaine de jours elle faisait escale
chez laurent ruquier dans on n'est pas
couché et l'animateur l'a reçu avec les
honneurs en lui faisant une bonne petite
blague dont il a le secret voilà on n'a
plus le temps de faire d'enfants en
france pour relancer la natalité nous
avons invité ce soir notre miss france
ça devrait vous donner des idées
alors laurent qui at il abusé avec ses
blagues de mauvais goût en tout cas
cette semaine sur le plateau de c'est à
vous l'animateur persiste et signe je
pense que quand on fait un concours miss
france on sait qu'on fait un concours de
beauté et qu' il faut être d'une
hypocrisie pour reprendre ce genre de
soi disant bozouls polémique le week-end
dernier c'est sur le plateau des
terriens du samedi que miss france a été
malmené par un laurent baffie sans
filtre on
heureusement vaima la mafia mais c'est
une femme de caractère est plein de
second degré elle a réussi à remettre le
sniper à sa place attention vous allez
finir au coin c'est la plus belle c'est
revenir maîtresses cvo pleinement
excusez-vous d'abord je m'excuse
maîtresse je tolère pour cette fois mais
malgré sa forte personnalité notre miss
france reconnaît tout de même certains
dérapages trop fréquent lors de ses
apparitions publiques
quand je sais qu'il ya une main qui
commence à descendre un peu trop bas
tout de suite je réagis soit je lui met
un coup de coude soit je lui dis ta main
tu l'enlèves j'ai un sale caractère et
s'il me cherche il ne trouve alors selon
vous est ce si facile d'être miss france
et surtout êtes vous choqué par le
traitement médiatique des miss france en
général
[Musique]
est ce que vous trouvez que la miss
france et en venir les miss france ont
malmené quant à vienne sur les plateaux
faire la promotion d'après élection j'ai
pas trouvé des missions comme ça mais je
trouve que c'est bien elle se laisse pas
faire là dessus ouais c'est très belle
elle est magnifique
j'aurais plutôt aux femmes les salariés
sur sa aux femmes j'ai des messieurs
alors je vais commencer fait commencer
par voilà y'a badara bèye par le
déambulateur
oui moi je trouve qu'elle a du répondant
et comme ça ne me choque pas ce qu'il
veut et dit dans la mesure où
manifestement elle en a sous le pied
sans nom
et c'est justement demain qu'elle fait
la preuve et de son intelligence et de
sang ce grain de second degré et de sa
subtile nom dans le livre des vagues de
baffin qu'on connaît par coeur et ben
franchement moi ça va pas ça dérangeant
mais c'est ainsi il y avait un jeu avec
elle donc c'est insupportable autant
qu'ils aient autant chercher chez
ardisson avec baffie c'est insupportable
et depuis deux des temps ancestraux isa
les miss france sont mises en avant
comme des bouts de viande on les voit
arriver à mener leurs notes
au contraire la preuve du contraire
quant à une ombre mais pas quand on y
pense mais leurs tuteurs ont des boutons
lors pas défendre ruquier la première
fois j'avais déjà dit que c'est pas
acceptable
il en remet une couche il aurait dû
sexualis à numériser le cabernet les
promos sont sexistes en tout cas et
heureusement qu'elle a une forte
personnalité et où d'autres qu'elle
aurait craqué merci acceptable on va
demander aux meilleurs amis de laurent
wauquiez alors moi je vais je doive être
course est mise pour moi c'est une miss
à buzz elle ne pense qu'à ça pour faire
de la télé derrière et je n'exagère est
là elle est là pour représenter la
france
elle a été élue pour être jolie c'est
tout ce qu'on lui demande je termine je
termine et quand elle répond je suis pas
là pour que les mecs se brancherait
dimache alors tu dois bien parler tu
dois être jolie s'est pas concours
d'éloquence d'intelligence tu as été élu
parce que tu es belle et un beau sourire
elle veut faire que du buzz et faire de
la télé alors je ne peux sont absents
parce que vous dites et de seconde dont
seulement 2 secondes et combien ça qui
entend lille et les propos de marie
d'orphelins ce qu'elle a vécu après son
élection que sortie agressé avait des
mains baladeuses des gens qui se jette
sur elle
soit parce que les miss france etc et
qu'elle est venu pour faire un concours
de beauté qu'on donnait manqué de
respect jeté sur elle et lui mettre la
main aux fesses arrêter deux secondes
grosse bêtise et je vous rappelle que
l'agression dans ce sens depuis le
premier jour que dieu fait ce que je
peux répondre s'ils voulaient le faire à
des agressions sexuelles cinq à dix ans
de prison
avec la sauce à corriger leurs noms mais
comme à mes côtés et y avait deux
secondes je crois le con qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on fait des blagues
et après ça mais c'est une plus grosse
bague et après ça dégénère et après les
gens qui sont dans la rue se sont
autorisés à faire tout et n'importe quoi
on ne doit pas laisser ce genre de
dérapage a malheureusement c'est qu'on
mélange tout c'est que judas thorax et
une agression une latina grise nord
il continue à tous les gens qui le garde
boue ça veut dire tu es jolie alors moi
un habitant qui dit à son invité comme
quand vous êtes là il y aura des bébés
parce qu'on va demander devant la télé
oui ça me dérange excusez moi voilà
voilà voilà voilà c'est tout on m'a
énervé j'ai mes gars du moderne à venir
mais sa part des enfants
voilà la future rue clark s'il vous
plaît je voudrais juste parler parce que
je suis une femme aussi vu alors là on
oublie souvent et franchement moi je
suis assez d'accord avec mathieu c'est à
dire que on a droit d'avoir aussi c'est
peut-être considéré par certaines comme
un regard machiste mais moi je trouve
que c'est important aussi qu'elle arrête
d'être en combat contre tout le monde
qui a le droit de faire une blague les
prix selon elle il faut pas galant jar
et the legend et comprendre
deux fois là visiblement il faudrait
faire durer soupe au lait on dirait
qu'elle part en croisade mois
elle est belle c'est une reine de beauté
basta soit belle je sais quoi arrêter
jour de la pub